you're an outspoken fellow you're
[Music]
interesting real loudmouth Hedgehog in
the suit you're an outspoken little
fellow have an acorn well okay we are
living through turbulent times all the
people going on well I'll tell you we
have this new president Donald Trump had
the reality show I'm curious what's your
take you you must you must have thoughts
on mr. Donald Trump you well here's my
thought on Donald Trump I think one of
the reasons people hate him so much and
why I hate him so much is because he
really shoved into our faces
how not progressive and evolved America
is it we we are not as progressive as we
thought we were because I think there
was a lot of back patting going on when
we elected Obama twice it was like check
it out it's a black president yeah
you're welcome
we're pretty cool America 21st century
pretty nice and then you know eight
years of a black president and we our
choices were this insanely qualified
woman and then a racist scrotum dipped
in cheeto dust and
[Applause]
so like in other words it's like we
couldn't go from black guy to what it
was it was too much it was clear that
like a big part of the country while
Obama was president on the outside
they're like well this is very nice but
internally they were clearly going black
and just freaking out so it's almost
like it's like imagine going skydiving
for the first time and the minute your
feet hit the ground and you're freaked
out someone runs up it goes
let's go bungee jumping right now there
you go I need a week on the couch - just
eat wheat sins and watch old Black Adder
episodes like I need so right now Donald
Trump is our racist palate cleanser
we're just the country is eating Wheat
Thins
and watching all by the way we will
eventually have a woman probably very
soon have a woman president and then
after she serves her terms the choice
will be like an insanely qualified gay
guy and then a Klansman with the ass
like cut out of his jeans let's see what
the glans with his ass so just try to
just as best you can stay active during
the palate cleanser stay active while
America sits on the couch and has Wheat
Thins
all right and look at the scrotum dip in
cheeto dust and just trying to go
but you know they could still time to
carve it on Mount Rushmore giant orange
scrotum put that right to the left
blinken it was Lincoln's dream and
change Lincoln's face was going like
this like I think that's been a New
Yorker cover
you